the greatest people are self-managing
they don't need to be managed you if
they know what if once they know what to
do they'll go figure out how to do it
they don't need to be managed at all
what they need is a common vision and
that's what leadership is what
leadership is is having a vision being
able to articulate that so the people
around you can understand it and getting
a consensus on a common vision we wanted
people that were insanely great at what
they did but we're we're not necessarily
those seasoned professionals but who had
on at the tips of their fingers and in
their passion the latest understanding
of where technology was and what we
could do with that technology and who
wanted to bring that to lots of people
so the neatest thing that happens is
when you get a core group of you know 10
great people that it becomes
self-policing as to who they let into
that group so I consider the most
important job of someone like myself is
recruiting agonized over hiring we had
interviews I go back and look at some of
the interviews agenda they would start
at 9:00 or 10:00 in the morning and go
through dinner
a new interviewee would talk to
everybody in the building at least once
maybe a couple of times and then come
back for another round of interviews and
then we'd all get together and talk
about it at least to my mind was when we
finally decided we liked them enough to
show them the Macintosh prototype and
then you snap them down in front of it
and if they just kind of were bored or
said this is a nice computer we don't
want it we wanted their eyes to light up
and then to get really excited and then
we knew they were one of us and
everybody just wanted to work not
because it was work that had to be done
but it was because something that we
really believed in that was just gonna
really make a difference and that's what
kept the whole thing going we all wanted
exactly the same thing instead of
spending our time arguing about what the
computer should be we all knew what the
computer should be and we just went and
did we went through that stage and Apple
where we went out and we thought oh
we're gonna be a big company let's hire
professional management we went out and
hired a bunch of professional management
it didn't work at all most of them were
bozos they knew how to manage but they
didn't know how to do anything and so
well if you're a great person why do you
want to work
for somebody you can't learn anything
from and you know what's interesting you
know who the best managers are there are
the great individual contributors who
never ever want to be a manager but
decide they have to be a manager because
every no one else is going to be able to
do as good a job as them after hiring
two professional managers from outside
the company and firing them both jobs
gambled on Debbie Coleman a member of
the Macintosh team 32 years old an
English literature major with an MBA
from Stanford
Debbie was a financial manager with no
experience in manufacturing I mean
there's no way in the world anybody else
would give me this chance to run this
kind of operation and I don't kid myself
about that this is an incredible high
risk both for myself personally and
professionally and for Apple as the
company they put a person like myself in
this job I mean they're really betting
on a lot of things we're betting that my
skills and organizational effectiveness
you know override all those you know
lack of technology lack of experience
lack of you know time and manufacturing
so it's a big risk and I'm just an
example in every single person on the
Mac team all most of your you know
entry-level person you could say that
about this is a place where people were
afforded incredibly unique opportunities
to prove that they could do it could
they could write the book again
inscribed inside the casing of every
Macintosh unseen by the consumer are the
signatures of the whole team this is
Apple's way of affirming that their
latest innovation is a product of the
individuals who created it not the
corporation